hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein sehr
spezielles video und zwar hat man eine
follower in über instagram über die
private nachrichten diesen
rezeptvorschlag gegeben und ich dachte
erst mal so ist das wirklich eine rezept
weil es hat einfach nur so zwei zutaten
und sorgte und kekse aber rausgekommen
ist das so cool ist und da habe ich mir
gedacht ich mach das nach ich weiß
leider deinen namen nicht mehr also wenn
du das siehst danke für die inspiration
und ich hab jetzt keine schokopudding da
deswegen machen wir ihnen heute selber
aber es sind im endeffekt einfach
wirklich nur zwei zutaten pudding und
kekse und raus kommt ein gestreifter
pudding keks kuchen also ist auf jeden
fall bis zum ende dran
für den schokopudding benötigen wir
milchbar cacau speisestärke und zucker
und außerdem kekse hier benötigen wir
einmal cacau kicks und normale
butterkekse also bevor sie jetzt zu
missverständnissen kommt mit fertig
pudding meine ich diesen fertig
schokopudding aus der tüte den habe ich
gar nicht da aber es ist eine gute
gelegenheit um euch zu zeigen wieder
ganz schnell selber geht und zwar nehme
ich jetzt sie die milch gibt die hälfte
davon in meinem kopf scheint den job
aber noch nicht ein sie mit die drei
anderen zutaten also zucker kakao und
speisestärke und verrührt das mit der
restlichen milch türmchen frei und dann
machen wir es den herd an
[Musik]
und weil der ba cacau sehr trocken ist
er ist er stark enthüllt also nimmt dann
nicht den trinker kauf dass ein bisschen
schwierig das klümpchen frei zu reden
geht aber dann noch ungefähr eineinhalb
minuten
und jetzt habe ich den herd
eingeschaltet und sobald ihr merkt dass
die milch hoch steigen will gibt die
kakaomasse dazu und rührt einfach
ständig um das einmal aufkochen und dann
ist der pudding fertig
und sobald die bläschen aufsteigen ist
der pudding fertig der ist nämlich ist
schön eingelegt durch die speisestärke
heraus und ihr könnt ihr müsst aber
nicht wir können das jetzt noch durch
ein sieb geben damit der komplett
klümpchen freies ich mach das jetzt und
dann geht es weiter
[Musik]
und das war es jetzt auch schon mit der
vorbereitung wir können direkt anfangen
zu schichten der pudding muss dabei noch
warm bzw heiß sein also nicht abkühlen
lassen und jetzt nehme ich mir ein
tablett wo ich das ganze drauf servieren
möchte außerdem noch meinen tortenring
können auch irgendwas anders hin
gegenstände die die kekse einfach vorne
und hinten festhalten damit sie nicht
umkippen und jetzt nehmen wir uns immer
einen dunklen keks bestreichen denen mit
unserem pudding und dann müssen wir das
ganz einfach abwechselnd schichten könnt
doch ein wenig pudding auf den boden
streichen das ist quasi unser kleber
[Musik]
hallo ich bin die kicker aus der zukunft
und zwar bin ich schon gerade ein paar
schritte weiter ist ein kleiner fehler
unterlaufen was aber absolut nicht
tragisch ist und zwar durch die kekse
hochkant reingelegt statt quer macht den
fehler nicht es ist wie gesagt nicht so
tragisch ihr könnt im nachhinein immer
noch erinnern aber ich habe gedacht es
ist ein bisschen korrekter wenn ich euch
das jetzt schon sage und jetzt viel spaß
im video
also ich muss sagen diese schichten
macht echt spaß und das ist auch so ein
rezept jeder hat die zutaten zu hause
also man muss nicht noch extra los genau
vor allem ich hab ja auch also meine
schwägerin die haben eine kinder- und
dann ist es auch immer so jetzt zeit für
aufwändige torte ist ja dann nicht mit
drei kindern zum beispiel aber das geht
er wirklich schnell und da können die
kinder sogar mithelfen
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt komplett fertig mit dem
schichten ich lasse jetzt auch den
tortenring dran für die stabilisation
und jetzt brauchen wir aber noch ein
bisschen von unserem kollegen habe ich
ihm übrig gelassen
ich habe übrigens ungefähr 40 kekse
verbraucht also 20 heller und 20 dunkle
und jetzt wird der kuchen wenn man das
so sagen darf oder die torte noch mit
pudding eingestrichen
ein fehler unterlaufen aber immer schön
das positive sehen gott sei dank ist es
mir jetzt aufgefallen denn das ganze
muss er so flach liegen das heißt wir
brauchen so ein bisschen mehr breite das
heißt ich nehme jetzt ganz einfach den
tortenring art und dann stürzt sich das
und da machen wir wie gehabt weiter
jetzt habe ich rundherum alles
eingestrichen und jetzt nämlich den
tortenring ab und dann streiche ich noch
die seiten ein
sobald ihr dann zufrieden seid und alles
schön glatt verstrichen habe ich werde
es aber gleich auf ein fach das
serviertablett ein bisschen saubermachen
gebt mir das in den kühlschrank und zwar
für zwei stunden in der zeit werden die
kekse schön weich der pudding härtet aus
der wird kalt und dann zeige ich euch
den coolen anschnitt
[Musik]
also ich habe jetzt mein kuchen über
nacht abkühlen lassen
das könnt ihr natürlich auch da wird
auch nichts mache ich das verspreche ich
euch am nächsten tag solltet ihr es dann
aber wirklich anschneiden und wir
schneiden das jetzt nicht gerade anwalt
und würde meiner das muster nicht
erkennen da bist du so einen kleinen
trick und zwar habe ich mein messer am
bis nimm dir so ein messer mit
wellenschliff und dann habe ich das hier
in heißes wasser getunkt einmal ganz
kurz abtrocknen und dann können wir das
rautenförmig anschneiden
[Musik]
also abschließend muss ich echt sagen
ich bin begeistert von dem rezept die
kekse sind total weich geworden das
ganze hat nicht lange gedauert und ihr
habt so eine coole optik da werden eure
gäste euch bestimmt fragen hast du
gemacht hast du gezaubert oder was ist
das also ich möchte noch mal ganz kurz
die konsistenz zeigen wir euch das ist
kann es nicht mehr wann schaut mal also
es ist schon ziemlich weich und er
schmeckt hat so wie man sich das
vorstellt kekse mit pudding ich genieße
das jetzt aber noch mit kaffee und da
freue ich mich wenn ihr beim nächsten
mal einschaltet genau die mengenangaben
steht immer und in der infobox sie
müssen einfach aufklappen dann könnte
das ganze nachmachen freue mich über
eure fotos mit dem hashtag hieß kitchen
auf instagram und dann sehen wir uns im
nächsten spitzenspiel
[Musik]